hello my name is Nicolette and in this
talk I want to present our paper PPP
computers and extremo combinatorics and
this is a joint work with woman
so let's start by talking about Ram's
history
so in Ramsey's theorem it's it says that
if you have an edge coloring of the
complete graph and two to the N vertices
and you use two colors to color in each
of the edges then you will have a
monochromatic leak that has the size of
at least eight over two
so Ramsey's theorem guarantees that a
certain substructure namely this
monochromatic leak exists if the
collection of objects namely the
vertices is sufficiently large
a similar sort of theorem is known as
the adash auto theorem and it says that
if you have a family of insects whose
carnalia is greater than m to the power
n times n factorial then you will have
an insulin flower of size n plus one and
recall that a sunflower is a collection
of sets that all pairwise intersect in
the same set that we call the kernel and
then each of the sets they they sort of
have pedals because they have unique
elements that are not in this curve and
I sort of tried to illustrate that with
this with these circles that I that I
put on this slide
um so both of these so what is sort of
in common with the what are these two
theorems have in common so they they
both it's they're both examples of
extreme combinatorics so extreme
combinatorics studies collections of
objects and the relation between the
size of the collection and emergence of
a certain subtraction
and
um
so if this collection of objects is
sufficiently large such that the
theorems guarantee that the subductor
exists then this induces a total search
Problem and in particular if the
substructure can be efficiently verified
it induces a total search problem that's
in tfnp
um so the problem that we ask in in this
in this work is what is the complexity
of total search problems that are
induced by extremely combinatorics
um and note that both Ramsay and the
sunflower problem the problems that are
induced by the ethereums are going to be
easy to solve If you're sort of given
the collections explicitly
so in order to make the problem
non-trivial what we do is we consider an
implicit representation of the of the
collections in in nested so for the case
of Ramsey what we have is we have a
circuit that computes the edge current
of the of the graph so you can give this
circuit an index of two separate
vertices and then you will get back the
the color of the edge between these two
vertices
so the implicit Ramsay problem is given
a circuit that computes this Edge
coloring finds an output I'm going to
Chromatic click that has a size of an
original this is going to be a set of of
indices into this into this collection
and note that this Canon mdp verifier
efficiently so it does belong to tfnp
similarly for sunflower what we do is we
have a circuit that where you give it an
index into the collection and then it
outputs a representation of the I so if
you give the input I it's going to give
a representation of the ith element as a
characteristic vector and then you're
asked to find an insulin flower of size
n plus one and this can also be
efficiently verified
show that Ramsay and sunflower are pwpp
hard
and
um so I'll and for Ramsay it it uses
something called the graph hash product
that I'll sort of that I'll go through
now because we'll be we'll be needing it
later in this talk
so in the graph hash products uh what we
do is we we basically want to use an
oracle that solves the Ramsay problem to
find collisions in a hash function so
and this first thing is is just effect
so there are randomized constructions of
a graph on true to the N over four
vertices that do not contain a
monochromatic leak of size 7 over 2.
so suppose we have one of these one of
these graphs and we have a hash function
that shrinks it takes in in bits and
outputs n over four bits
so if we if we consider the the
so it then we also have this other graph
where what we do is we we take the um
uh we we color if we if you have two two
vertices uh the color between these two
vertices is going to be determined by
hashing each of the vertices and then
taking the color from the smaller graph
so and and sort of the interesting thing
here is that we we know that this model
graph does not have a click and in
particular this larger graph is is
exactly large enough such that the
Ramses theorem applies so we know that
it it it it must have a click and in
particular this Clique must have been
introduced by the collisions in the in
the hash function so if if the Ramsay
solver gives us back a a monochromatic
leak we can use that to find a collision
in the in the hash function and this is
sort of the approach that's used to show
pwpp hardness of Ramsay and sunflower
so what we do in this work is that we we
characterize pwpp and PPP via extremo
combinatorics
so we show that pwpp is captured by weak
theorems in extremely combinatorics of
which
Ramsay and sunflower are
arguably the the case while PPP is
captured by a strong theorems and I'll
go into more detail with exactly what
this means but essentially a strong
theorem you will have a a a tight bound
on the size of the collection while the
weak theorems you will you will not
um and so we we show that pwpp and PPP
are captured by these two different
Notions of extreme and combinatorics
theorems and then we also significantly
increase the number of compute problems
for uh for both of these classes
uh because both of these classes were
like unlike PPA or PLS they were not
known to have as many natural uh
complete problems and um
and we we sort of significantly expand
on this uh on this set of problems
and at a high level what we're doing is
we're using efficient encodings that
sort of translate these substructures
that we're looking for into collisions
in a circuit such that we can use the
use the pigeon pitching solver
so other complete problems that were
known for PPP are bleach those theorem
which was shown by sotiaki some patakis
and ciudelis who also showed a
completeness for the related constrained
sis problem which is related to to a
[ __ ] is related to cryptography then
kubachik and baklavic showed that a
version of the discrete logarithm
problem is also known to be it should be
complete for a for PPP
also in a concurrent work
pasaka yanakakis and papa dimitriu show
that a version of the Eros Colorado
theorem is also complete for PPP
and note that this is this is
essentially so I will be showing
basically a version of this results but
know that note that there are statement
of the Edo's collateral theorem is
significantly different than than ours
and I'll expand upon that when we when
we actually get to the definition of the
of the following
so
let's define these classes that we're
that we're going to be working with so
the the classes are defined by their
canonical problems so uh let's start
with the first one which is the weak
pigeon so in wheat pitching you're given
some shrinking circuit and as to find a
collision so since this the circuit is
shrinking by the pigeonhole principle
there there must be a collision somehow
so if you have in pigeons and you put
them in over two pigeon holes there must
be two pigeons in the in the same home
um and note that this is this is what I
mean with uh with a weak theorem because
clearly if there are in pigeons in an N
over two pigeon holes either like many
of the holes will will contain two
pigeons or one of the holes will contain
a lot of pigeons so the the condition
that we have two pigeons in the same
hole is sort of is sort of not a very
strong uh condition that we that we get
from this other thing so
um
so this is the wheat pigeon and pwpp is
defined as the set of all problems that
are reducible in polynomial times to
repeat
then similarly we have the the pigeon
and here we have a circuit that's not
shrinking so it takes in in bits and
also outputs and bits and here
um we're asked either to give a
pre-image of zero or to find equation
and here we we sort of use uh what we
call a strong property of the of the
pigeonhole principle because if we have
in pigeons and we have in Pigeon holes
then either all of the pigeon holes have
a pigeon in which case C is essentially
a permutation uh or there must be two
pigeons in the in the in the same hole
so
this is this is a stronger version of
the of the same theorem and this again
defines the flash PPP and we sort of
show that this notion of so so for the
pitching what we have is uh we have this
type bound namely in pigeons and in
Pigeon holes and then we know that if
the condition uh named a collision that
we're looking for is not satisfied some
other property must be satisfied and
then we can use that to to name it that
is a permutation and then we can use
that to uh
to to to define a total research problem
um okay so the result that I'll be going
through now is to show that this error
collado theorem is indeed uh is indeed
complete for uh for pwpp
so what we do is we take a family of
sets and then we say that this family
upsets is an intersecting family
if no two sets from the family are are
disjoint so all of the all of the sets
sort of intersect sometimes
in 1961 showed that if you have uh they
they sort of gave conditions uh they
gave bounce on the sizes of these
intersecting families and their bounds
were like significantly more General
than than what I'm presenting to you
here but we also do present
significantly more General versions of
this Eros collateral problem but sort of
in the interest of of
um keeping the presentation uh short and
simple I we choose the special case so
if you have a universe of size 2N so so
some set of size 2N and then you
consider subsets of this set of size n
then so any intersecting family of
insets must have a size of at most two n
minus one choose n minus one
and essentially how this bound comes
about is suppose we take these two n
elements and then we fix one of the
elements so let's say we choose the
first element and then we say that all
all of the sets in the intersecting
family has to contain this particular
limit
uh and then we consider the remaining
two n minus 1 elements from the universe
then we have to choose n minus one of
these and there are two n minus one twos
n minus one ways to uh to uh do this and
and this is how the how the bound is uh
is uh obtained
and note that this means that if we have
more than two n minus one choose n minus
one a family of like if we have a family
of insects of of size larger than this
bound then there must be two uh two sets
that are in fact uh disjoint and this is
this induces the the total charge
problem
um so we're going to define a problem
that we call weak errors
where essentially like the sunflower
thing the circuit is going to encode
this collection of objects if you're
going to give it an index of the of the
ice set and then it's going to return to
you the characteristic Vector of the uh
of the uh of the ice set so it's
basically a bitmap where the ones
indicate which element from the universe
are contained within the ielt set and
here we sort of we we guarantee that
this circuit is a larger than
than the than the Bound By by saying
that its input size is Alpha which we
Define as a log 2 and minus one choose n
minus 1 rounded up plus one
so so this guarantees that that we have
more sets than than we need
and then we say that a solution
uh so it what we want to say is that if
we have like for an arbitrary circuit we
will have this errors Colorado theorem
this hydrosclub condition hold and there
must be two different sets but the way
we choose this representation it's it's
not guaranteed that
that a particular index actually
represents an inset so so I might say
that the the first set is empty set or
it contains all the elements in the in
the universe and we sort of because this
is this is a wrong
this doesn't conform to the conditions
required by the Eros Colorado theorem so
we say that this is also a solution we
allow evidence of the fact that the
encoding is wrong to also be a peer
solution and similarly if we have two
indices that encode the same set this is
a collision and this would also mean
that the Eros Colorado condition does
not apply so this is also allowed to be
a to be a solution
and finally we have the actual condition
that we are like the the actual case
that we're interested in namely that if
all of the indices are in fact distinct
and they are all insets then the errors
collado theorem applies and then we have
to find two different sets
um so what we show is that this weak ekr
thing is is pwpp heart
so
um
yes uh what we're going to do is we're
essentially going to be using a covering
Coatings so we we want to map uh we want
to map
uh like these different like these three
conditions we sort of want to map back
and forth between collisions and and
these things so what we're going to use
is these carbon colleagues and carbon
Coatings allow us to encode so we have a
universe of some fixed size n and we are
only interested in in cases of this
universe then we can use cover encodings
to sort of optimally encode this
so basically we we take all the case
sets and then we order them
lexicographically and this this is our
encoding so if if you want to encode a
given set you're give you give me 2N
bits as input and then I'll give you the
index into this lexicographical ordering
of this particular set
and then the decoding function obviously
does the opposite
note that
um these functions can in fact be be
made
efficient and also the the functions
like if I give it an input so we're
going to be using this with insets of a
universal size 2N but if I give this
cover encoding function something that
does not have a hemingway.n
like the the output is going to be
meaningless it's not going to correspond
to the actual set but it's it's still
going to be well defined and in fact it
will be arbitrary so if if we give the
the cover encoding uh something that's
that's not an inset uh the the output
can be whatever and this turns out to be
important and I'll get back to that in a
bit
okay so the first thing we want to do is
we want to establish pwpp hardness so
this means that
um
we are given some shrinking circuit C
Prime
and by the Merkel Danga construction we
can sort of like exactly how much it
shrinks doesn't really matter that much
so let's just assume that for for
Simplicity that this circuit shrinks by
two bits so we have some circuit that
takes in Alpha bits and then it outputs
Alpha minus two bits this is our weak
region instance that we want to find
collisions in
uh so we're going to build an instance
of address Colorado as it follows so
we're going to take these Alpha minus
two bits and then we're going to
pre-pend uh two zeros to it
and then we're going to put it through
the through the cover decoding function
and basically when we when we when we
prepare when we prepend these two zeros
uh because we use the lexical graphical
ordering uh we will we we know that the
result is not going to contain one
so so whatever sits so we give this
cover decoding function uh the index of
some set and then it gives us back the
set and and we we know that
the the
that the cover decoding function has to
give us something that does not contain
one and also by correctness it it has to
uh has to give us something that's
actually adds it like that's just
correctness of the of the of the
decoding function
and this means that sort of a
correctness of this decoding function
all the outputs are guaranteed to be
overlapping and sets
this means that all the solutions that
are left are going to be the collisions
and these collisions allow us to find
collisions in the in the original
pitching instance because there's a
covered decoding function is intactive
so this is basically how we establish
hardness
in order to establish so so one thing
that's interesting about our work here
is that unlike other
classes of tfnp like a PLS or PPA
there's a natural algorithm that sort of
uh solves the the problem and this means
that oftentimes inclusion results are
going to be fairly easy to to a show
whereas the hardness results might be
hard
okay well in our case it actually seems
to be the opposite like variants of this
graph hash product seem to work in a lot
of different cases but what was the most
challenging part was actually showing
inclusion
um so I'll also be showing inclusion now
for this week uh Edward theorem
so
uh okay so so this should be so so the
the C the topmost C is correct the other
one should be C frame so we use C Prime
to denote the weak pitch in instance and
C to denote the ekr instance
and so uh we we have some instance of of
a ekr
and it's going to give us
um so we we give it an index and it's
going to give us back the corresponding
set
this is going to be the the C
and then we're going to get back some
bitmap some representation of this of
this insect and then what we're going to
do is we're going to case depending on
whether or not this set contains one so
if if it if it does contain one we're
going to flip all the bits and if if it
does not contain one we're going to
leave it be uh we call this to normalize
the the lack of a better term and this
essentially means that
um they said we're going to get
we'll always start with a with a zero
and then we're going to take the set I'm
going to put it through the cover
encoding function
and then we're going to get back the
index of this of this particular set
and we know that because all of these
steps do not contain one
uh that's the cover like the the
encoding that we get uh for any of these
sets is always going to start with the
zero so the first bit is always going to
be a zero so we're just going to get rid
of this bit
and uh
and then then we're going to keep these
remaining Alpha minus one bits and note
that this is indeed an instance of of a
weak pigeon because we have a circuit
that shrinks by by one bit
and essentially so what we want to argue
now is that we can basically find any of
the solutions that we have to the eqr
theme so if if we don't have something
that's actually an insects that like I
said this encoding function would just
like arbitrarily map it into into one of
the other sets which in which creates a
collision
uh because the cover encoding function
is is a injective
um
so so we so
yes and um
another thing if we if we have a
collision like uh if this uh
if this ekr thing have two sets that
that correspond to the to the to the
same thing uh
uh then again by injectivity of this uh
carbon coding and this normalization uh
this will
also produce a collision in the in the
weak patient instance that we that we
create and finally if we have two
disjoint sets uh since we're working
with nsets over a universe of size 2N
the only disjoint sets are going to be
uh like asset and then the complement of
that set and here like the normalization
uh process is going to map both of these
into the into the same representative uh
because we're going to take the
compliment uh and this so so this Maps a
solution of the third type from ekr into
a into Collision which allows us to use
the weak pigeon uh solver to to find it
um
and so note that ekr is is a strong
theorem so this bound is is tight so if
we do have an interest acting family
then then like this is the this is the
largest possible you can you can get and
it's a and it's a type bound and in
addition the largest intersecting family
has to contain either a n like like the
so let's say the the elements of the
universe are the numbers one to two n it
either has to contain uh the sets one to
n or it has to contain the complement
from n plus one to two n
and we can we can use this to to create
a strong version of the of the ekr
ethereum so we Define a problem called
the Eros Colorado problem which again so
so now we we have a
now we want to ensure that the
collection has the has the precise
number of of the limits that we need so
we have this Alpha bits as input and
then
we're going to keep the the first three
types of solutions and then we're going
to add a new type of solution so if the
collection is indeed maximal without
containing any uh any disjoint sets then
it it either has to con it it has to
consume one of these two sets so we
allow this as a as a as a solution so if
we have the largest possible collection
of items
so so basically we will we will either
have
um
either one of these two sets have to
have a pre-image or we have to have a
or we have to have two different sets if
the if this collection is is encoded
correctly and sort of to to guarantee
that we have the correct size of the of
the Circuit of the collection what we do
is we sort of artificially add this uh a
bound on these values X and Y so they
have to be strictly less than the bound
and what we show in the paper is that
the Eros Colorado theorem is in fact PPP
hard
or if PVP complete sorry it's it says
heart here but the but it's actually PVP
complete the adage address Colorado
theorem
and we also show this for a
significantly more a general version of
the of the theater's collateral theorem
we also consider other problems from
extreme combinatorics so we we consider
the the following problems so by spurner
on anti-chains Kaylee on spanning trees
and
and these other problems so we we
consider the
implicit total drug problems that are
induced by all of these problems and
what we and and then we show some some
various bombs so the balance that we
show are the are the following so the
Eros Colorado a sprinter anti-chain and
the Kaylee on spanning trees has the
probability that their weak versions are
pwpp complete while there are strong
versions are PVP compute and for mental
and to run and World Sabo it's a it's a
bit more complicated in the sense that
we were not able to show as strong
bounds as we as we were for the for the
for the other problems and it's sort of
unclear
problem it defines a hierarchy basically
so
yeah if you'll note here we have this in
the in the definition of the of the two
hunting we have this parameter r
so uh it basically creates a hierarchy
of these of these problems and it's sort
of unknown whether or not uh
like where it fits exactly in relation
to vwpp and MPP
um
yeah so to summarize what we do is we
give a new take on PPP and pwpp in terms
of weak and strong theorems from extreme
combinatorics
so yeah so so our work uh suggests that
maybe the reason showing inclusion for
Ramsay and sunflower has been difficult
is due to the lack of type type bombs
especially in relation to to PPP so
thank you very much for your attention